HEATHER: Hi.
I'm Heather, and we're here
at the Certification Lounge
at Next '17.
And I'm with Neel.
Neel, can you tell us a
little bit about yourself?
NEEL SHAPUR: Sure.
So I'm Neel Shapur, director
of PwC's Cloud Practice.
I'm also helping drive the
Google Cloud Go-To-Market
offerings.
So I'm right now cloud
architect certified,
and I have also taken the
big data engineer exams.
Personally, it's great that
I'm current with the latest
technologies.
For PwC, our customers
are just getting
started on this journey.
And now this is a very
evolving cloud ecosystem.
And they need somebody
who has been there before.
And these certifications
helps validate our credentials
and when we can take
them to this journey.
So PwC, we are a
[? multi-sponsor ?] for Google,
Google Cloud.
But we have been a strategic
partner since 2015.
And we are actually [INAUDIBLE]
ourselves using Google G Suite.
And then we have
maybe, oh, a thousand
DCP projects also
[INAUDIBLE] within the firm.
So we have gone through
this journey ourselves,
and now we are
helping our customers
take a similar journey.
HEATHER: Awesome.